oh yeah hey what's going on everybody
for first we feast I'm Sean Evans and
you're watching hot ones the show with
hot questions and even hotter wings and
today I'm joined in studio by ja Rule
hot ones you see I got my glasses on I
want to see I don't want you to see me
crap
here's how the show works we have 10
questions 10 hot wings and 10 sauces
gotcha
as we move along in the show the the
chicken wings get hotter and so do the
questions the wings get so hot in fact
that you might need to tap out you might
have to just say I've had it I need to
get out of here and your safe word is
it's murder
so you drop that ad-lib and just like
that you don't have to eat any more
wings we go right to the last question
and it's a wrap the light at the end of
the tunnel is a 30-second uninterrupted
plug if you don't make it through all
ten wings through all ten sauces I take
half your plug okay alright ja Rule
Jerry your hot ones
the first one Texas Pete hot sauce touch
the Supreme pardon variety kindergarten
stuff Texas pace is nothing we could do
Texas no problems girl all day
mmm
first question I was watching an
interview that nard were had with Tyler
the Creator recently right and nerd wars
thing is he brings gifts during all of
his interviews right and one of the
things that he gave Tyler the Creator
was a job rule condom haha yeah and I
have to know where did the ja rule
condom where did that idea like how did
that come into the world and have you
ever used one never use one never
trusted those but back in the days when
hip-hop was hip-hop we should do like
these great new promotional items to
give like the radio stations and PDS and
DJs when I made the record thug lovin
that was one of my motorized was jawohl
condom get your bug laughing so you're
already through one okay on to number
two now this this is a Tallulah hots a
little hot sauce alright a little more
of a kick but still like I scared a you
chalo uh-huh I watched some videos of
you recently and in them you were doing
Skype interviews with all these
different celebrities you know yeah you
talked to a lot of people I noticed that
your peak excitement you got most
excited when you're talking to Lil Wayne
about jail meal hacks yeah and his whole
thing was like with ramen and Doritos
and you got so hyped what's your go-to
meal hack and jelly
what's one of those things that you do
to make the shitty food that they serve
their better I used to make like this
like a kind of like a noodle casserole
[ __ ] I take the ramen noodles and then I
take some Jack Mac
put it in ramen noodles heat it up drain
the water but Jack and I can heat it up
a little while longer put a little bit
of sweetness sweet and sour like sauce
we had bought from commissary put that
on there
put it all together and it was kind of
like a so are there like recipes that
are floating around or is this like a
trial in air I got whole books they got
all jail books with just jail recipes
and it even got a book that I'll let you
know wipe from depend on which facility
you in what they have on their
commissary and what you can make in this
facility versus another facility really
it's that detailed that detail all right
all right
I'll Yucatec Oh Carribean habanero this
is it there's the one here
yep number three all right how you doing
so far thanks KITT
got some bullets all right there so I
was watching the trailer for follow the
rules yep
in in it you like your daughter brings
home a boyfriend for the first time yeah
and you have to meet them and you're
doing that thing in your sizing them up
you know that dad thing yeah and I got a
no are you a scary dad where is that
like well I'm gonna scary dude
I'm cool dad you know yeah I'm very
understanding as long as she's happy and
he's a good guy and you cheated or the
world right all's good in Henryville so
far though don't get too comfortable
don't get too comfortable ready for the
next one
not really but let's do it all right
latias hot pepper sauce
daddy's laddie daddy's still Caribbean
kind of like a mustard thing to it watch
can you look yeah kind of sweeter I
actually think number three is a little
bit worse than number all right so you
recently issued and I'll use your words
because it's a great quote a big [ __ ]
you to the media and I think from what I
understand it was like from a show that
you in a shot he did in Australia or
something likely to state late to the
stage whatever but you went and said a
big [ __ ] you to the media
and I think that your point was that
they cover controvert like the cover
skin go to the negative [ __ ] they don't
cover the positive thing in 2015 what
bothers you about the way the media
covers hip hop stereotypes every time I
meet people and I leave the room they
always say [ __ ] does that mean
yeah what the [ __ ] did you think I was
idiot rapper you know they're like I'm
educated I can speak well like you know
I said I can hold the conversation we
can talk [ __ ] politics we can talk
business we could throw stocks whatever
you know saying so I think I think
people still have this misconception of
what in hip-hop artists is nowadays I
mean how are you feeling so far I'm
alright alright right better than
expected worse than expected about what
you expected I'm in the middle even a
way to get to the fifth wing I'm in the
middle somewhere
oh hold on here oh there we go this one
is called pain as good louisiana-style
Oh pain is good that's like pain is love
is this guy it's that guy is that the
kid screaming right with holy [ __ ] I
don't like that so he looks like he's in
pain right I was do it pain is good good
oh yeah kind of smoky in there hot I
don't think anybody can spend as many
hours with DMX as you but not have a
crazy DMX story can you give me one from
the archives
oh man so many crazy I mean we from
stolen cars to arrest we we a stolen car
DMX story we're in Miami we're having a
[ __ ] great time you know records are
blowing up you know me and X are [ __ ]
moving out so full blow and the throws
like full blow oh yeah yeah yeah with me
and X are hot as fire crackers out there
X is in front of the hotel and he's got
this [ __ ] Benz yeah he's like yeah we
go he's like a cross we gonna pop it up
my checkride
let's go to go do this yeah I'm like
[ __ ] imma win you get the car from
the eyes my car
whatever I jump in the [ __ ] car with
eggs we go rat typical ex he's [ __ ]
Spain act crazy on the road cops pull us
over
capture the license of registration ex
gets to do not actually my car so now
I'm looking at him like old [ __ ] up what
what's about to happen here yeah come
and find out he stole the car from
Michael Kaiser it was Kaiser Scott I
worked with Def Jam I said he explains
this to the cop cops is all right it's
your label guys go out without me to get
where what are you guys alright you
don't have a license you don't have a
license you're not you guys won't be
going anywhere else in this car so call
somebody to come help me whatever X is
like [ __ ] it I don't worry about it
jumps out the car we take nothing less
than what he puts his thumb out like
this like the hitchhike and I'm like
yeah this can't be like this [ __ ] some
chick see gyro BMX on the side of the
[ __ ] Road like this with a thumbs out
waving cars down and [ __ ] she picks us
up she's hysterical she takes us to her
[ __ ] grandmother's house in the hood
the whole hood comes out grandma's
cooking us taking pics it was a great
day but if they got extol that car
though sonic stole that car there's
always some wood XV so the next one also
pain right in the title pain 100% hot
sauce oh I had this one before that
thing so you've conquered that one I've
had the pain I've been through the pain
we didn't get to this alright that's hot
that one's not even fair it just tastes
like metal yeah that was not there's
just no reason just good yeah that's the
thing about some of these hot sauces I'm
like well like what psychopath would
even enjoy this like who the [ __ ] would
even put this on a sandwich I will say
gotta swallow it quick Oh like you
thought you had a like in the trailer
and you didn't I know you know I was
like don't let it don't let it get it
all on your lips wasn't going in whoops
game over yeah it's a different this is
different flow whoo
so I saw you on Fox Business channel and
you were talking about the election yes
it seems like you're leaning Hilary
would that be fair to say I like you
like hell I like Hill what sorts of
things are you looking for in the next
president we got to take on some of
these issues what what's going on
throughout the country with all these
cops killing black folk we gotta we
gotta dig into these issues the next one
is Blair's original death sauce all the
way up to seven cruisin rule whoa what
the [ __ ] am i doing okay
it's the DEF sauce yeah now this I kind
of think is like a little bit easier
than the last one
I want to get your reaction about
something these are gonna be rap collabs
it seems like they're not being done
under one roof that's the best way to do
it when it's organic can you both there
and kind of you know coming up with
ideas [ __ ] together that's the best way
to do it all right number eight this is
Dave's temporary and sanity hot sauce
why why would he call it that maybe it's
just like exactly what it is
yeah rarely go crazy if you have this he
has another one that's hotter yeah Dave
makes two appearances on it on the
countdown [ __ ] day all right
let's do it
how many times have you done this
challenge we make it early girl huh I'm
not to be [ __ ] with when I come to
Wayne I'll play no Wayne I don't give a
[ __ ] I see you don't give a [ __ ] I'll be
wearing red and that he's not actually
wearing red hot right now this was a
white shirt a little white shirt when I
got here was white
this is gonna be bad so gonna be bad so
I read that you stayed and Saddam
Hussein's hunting lodge
when you perform for troops overseas
absolutely yes was Saddam Hussein's
hunting lodge more impressive or less
impressive than you were expecting less
impressive okay this is Dave's insanity
this will just go all the way insane
it's 36 times hotter than a jalapeno
agonizing [ __ ] so perusing your
Instagram and notice that cocktails come
up quite frequently it's kind of a theme
to pop up on Ja Rule's Instagram yeah
mimosa is making multiple appearances
and I wonder do you brunch yeah I love
brunch you know what I've had something
the other day this is a new one it was
called a Sangre osa I was great it was a
sangria mimosa it's like an orange juice
sangria kind of yeah it was [ __ ]
great all right last one so it's kind of
a tradition here to dab the last one
with a fresh are you [ __ ] crazy
everyone's done it hey if you don't want
to do it you don't have to do it
dab it how I'll show you so this is mad
dog 357 71 times hotter than a jalapeno
so the dab is you just go you got to be
careful though because there's a pink
the drop fresh one oh you don't want if
you don't want to do it you don't have
to do it I ain't scared of you
[ __ ] any everyone else did but
you know what if you don't want to it's
nothing
your dad will do now you're tapping the
glass I've got to get it out right
playing it fast and loose man whoa this
is gonna hurt oh oh oh yeah looks like
the dumbest show on the Internet
easy whoo whoa after no I know you
posted about it but I have to know your
reaction when you heard meat mill say
your name at the end of his drake this
track just don't bring my name into this
[ __ ] right that's all I'm saying
I mean one sold over 30 million records
I write all my old eggs so I was just
curious is that which one was posed to
me yes this is far from me at 50 i'ma if
this if you wanna compare this yeah tell
me about it to me it fit me if you can't
I want to need somebody get stabbed or
shot or something like that and then you
could have a beef just wasn't on records
we had physical competition so that made
me Street that made it about what's
going on in those streets - 50 cent
absolutely you know but that's well
documented you know what I'm sayin but
that's what I'm saying I thing was
physical as well as learn what people
fail to realize about the man 50 beef is
it wasn't just about me in 50 it wasn't
just about the record it was a lot of
backdoor [ __ ] they had to do it at - who
on a federal investigation veteran died
right
the feds came and seized our offices Def
Jam threw us off the label behind that
so not only was it was me against 50
against Eminem against Boston against
dear Mac so yeah lots of headaches lots
of headaches me against like 10 guys all
the d12 all the fifties guys so with me
against a whole slew of people when just
me by myself so that you have to factor
in that and he had the fact and the fact
that I didn't have a label anymore you
know I mean I couldn't make records you
know where my plan after pipeline you
know I'm saying it was no Twitter and no
Instagram and these things and
SoundCloud where I can just put you know
stuff on YouTube right it wasn't it
wasn't the same it wasn't the same
situation but you know I'm not making
any excuses with me in 50 what happened
in 50s is documenting this history
people are always gonna say John we lost
that battle whatever the case may be
whatever I'm gonna say it again for
those who didn't hit the first time if
if you want on wax I want in the streets
we're tied 1-1 people will see how this
thing turns out thank you for coming in
you were you had you said when you came
in here that you were gonna tap out you
didn't think you'd make it all the way
through but here you are 10 wings down
10 hot sauces I did it baby 10 questions
10 questions tonight sources I tackled
it all answer to go and I go you a
30-second plug all yours I'm steppin the
[ __ ] out okay instead of hot ones with
Sean Evans the show is just all about ja
Rule that's your camera
all right there 30 seconds on now to
rule York show wasn't really York City
ladies and gentlemen what I'm here to
promote in my 30 seconds a new shoe line
coming with Steve Matt and I think we
actually dropped August a new television
show with MTV very dope family show fun
you're gonna love it it's go follow
rules
Oh new album new album in works working
on genius loves company right now
probably come early next year and you're
doing an American tour right
yes mean Ashanti working on the world
tour not some lone killer stormy and
Ashanti and there will be an EP to go
along with that me and hug duet album EP
very dope so a lot of stuff into work
this wing is working you're busy as hell
man lot hand into in many honey pots job
I'm trying man I'm trying college is
expensive and you guys I got went down
to the gold man so you know I got one
already in this alright appreciate your
time no doubt man thanks a lot man just
cuz I don't give a [ __ ] I can't even
hear what you're saying so my balance on
fire is doing things for these so you
know really people say blood guys have
big dicks Jimmy you know I did a lot of
pay with shoe stores yeah yeah you
combat